avancer leur recul est là ou carrément
cessé de le faire ce vieux débat qui
refait surface régulièrement au canada
pourrait bientôt se régler au sud de
notre frontière
le sénat américain vient d'adopter le
premier projet de loi pour abolir
officiellement la pratique des changes
mandat deux fois par année pour ne
conserver qu'un seul or à l'heure
avancée d'été et le sénat pour une rare
fois l'a fait à l'unanimité
cinq jours avant d'être répliqué le
projet de loi devra être adopté par la
chambre des représentants et le
président lui-même mais si c'est le cas
le canada qui partagent des milliers de
kilomètres de frontières avec son
principal partenaire commercial aurait
tout intérêt à suivre la parade
nous
faut dire que cette pratique adopté plus
ou moins également par les provinces
canadiennes depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale a beaucoup de détracteurs entre
autres parmi les spécialistes du sommeil
on sait qu'après le changement d'art au
printemps il ya plus d'accidents de la
route plus d'accent de travail plus de
crises cardiaques donc de manquer une
heure de sommeil dont d'être privé d'une
heure de sommeil au printemps ça ait des
impacts au niveau de la population
le sénat merkin dit préférer leur avance
et qui offre une heure de lumière
supplémentaire en fin de journée plus
tôt que l'heure normale ou soleil ce
point plus tôt le matin dans la
population les avis sont actuellement
partagés entre les lève tôt et les
couche tard mais pour les experts la
réponse est simple au niveau biologique
donc pour favoriser le seul le sommeil
et les veilles c'est préférable art
normal si on constate la population
depuis juin dernier la société
canadienne se mêlent recommande de
mettre un terme aux changements d'art et
de remettre tout le pays al normal ici
norma grondin radio canada montréal